system at USC and yonk who's that
Berkeley now and probably is here
somewhere
so by system I'm gonna mean two specific
models marker decision processes and a
leanness system model and to some of you
this might sort of you know you mind to
about reinforcement learning too
although it might mean stochastic
adaptive control so it of course has
connections to both but the perspective
is a little bit different or fresh take
an online learning perspective of the
problem okay so I'm going to start with
just a quick overview of MDPs and
dynamic programming and then I'll talk
about bandit models and online learning
and then I'll talk about reinforcement
learning algorithm for unknown MVPs
based on posterior what's called
posterior sampling and then we'll see a
similar algorithm for unknown linear
stochastic systems okay so let me jump
right in huh so I'm gonna assume that we
have MDP with the final over a finite
state space the action space is also
finite and so if you are in state X and
you take action you then you make a
transition to the next state Y according
to some transition probability theta and
then we get a reward which is a function
of the current state and the action and
of course the controller gets to see
both the state and the reward and what
we care about is the expectation of the
long-term average of the reward right
and we would like to optimize that and
so we're gonna restrict our discussion
to what I call weakly communicating mdps
just to make sure that we guaranteed
existence of optimal cost and optimal
policy and of course we know that the
optimal value function satisfies this
bellman equation which is a fixed point
in the optimal cost and the relative
value function and of course there are
many algorithms known for finding
solution to this fixed point problem in
particular relative value iteration
algorithm is one particular way you
could find solution so
question is what can we do when the MDP
or the model is unknown
specifically the transition
probabilities are unknown and you know
one what one could try to do is one
could try to do system identification
and then based on that find the optimal
controller when many applications we
don't have that luxury we must learn and
control at the same time and the
question is okay so in that case what
can we do sometimes we you know we can
learn or estimate the parameters and
then come up with the control policy and
then based from that control policy you
get a control action etc when we can do
that without losing optimality we say
that in adaptive control it we say that
certainty coolants holds right but it's
well-known that many times it doesn't
hold right and the question is in that
case what can be done and specifically
the objective here is to find a learning
policy that that is optimal in the sense
that it has the fastest possible
learning rate rate or fastest possible
rate of converging to the optimal policy
okay so that's the specific objective
and of course that's the goal of
reinforcement learning and one of the
goals of stochastic adaptive control and
in fact were current you know one of the
earliest formulations of this was
actually given in Bora Bora in the early
eighties okay so one of the issues that
arises why certain sequence doesn't hold
is that you may not be doing enough
exploration so you the the learning
policy has to kind of trade-off
exploration and exploitation to be able
to kind of achieve this objective right
and of course that it's what it means is
that it's an online learning problem and
immediately that should remind you of
bandit models so let me kind of just
talk about bandit models so just a very
quick overview of a very very basic
setting so let's say that we have two
clients with unknown biases and we told
to play this game we can play this game
let's say 100 times each time we can
choose either Quine and we toss it and
if it
subheads we get a reward of $1 otherwise
we get you and we like to maximize our
payoff so kind of that tells you that
you know it's not enough to say well you
know first 50 times you can toss this
coin and then get an estimate of the
pious theta-1 and then next 50 times we
can toss this coin and get a estimate of
the vast cedar - that's not enough right
because that may not be the optimal
strategy so like - as I was saying we
like to maximize the expected long-term
total reward and sort of another way to
kind of ask the same question is in
terms of regret so we define that a
notion of regret
[Music]
so the first term here is the expect so
if you knew which of the two coins is
better meaning has a higher bias of
heads then this would be the expected
reward that you would get by just
playing that crime right and then the
second would be the this is the
expectation of the total reward that you
would get for under some learning policy
fee right and the difference of the two
is the regret right so the question of
you know what is the policy that can
that'll maximize the expected long-term
total reward is equivalent to sort of
minimizing the expected regret okay now
this this problem as I stated was given
by lion robins in the mid 80s and they
also gave a lower bound on any learning
policy and they showed that you you know
there is no a learning policy that can
get rigged that can achieve regret
better than locti so it cannot grow
slower than Lochte or in other words
convergence to the optimum cannot have
happened faster than Lochte buddy okay
that's the best that can happen and by
now of course you know you today morning
you heard about the UCB algorithm and
probably you know maybe everybody here
knows about the UCB algorithm so you
know we you see B algorithm is one
algorithm that can actually achieves
this lower bound as well so in that
sense it's order optimal and the way it
works is that you define an index for
each coin or each arm and it looks the
following so the first term here is just
the average reward that you got
from tossing coin I and the second term
is you can think of it as accounting for
the variance in your estimate but it is
our standard deviation in your estimator
it is really not that it is well you
know there is a so it is somehow you
know controlling how your exploration
for the various arms and the D algorithm
is very simple so you eat each instant
you pick the arm or the coin that has
the highest index value okay and so so
very rough intuition for this is the is
that this is sort of an upper conference
bound on your estimate of the unknown
parameter and you know at every instant
you should pick the coin that has the
highest upper conference bound which is
independent of what the distribution is
like so in that sense it is sort of you
know taking an optimistic decision so
this is an example of you know class of
learning policies that are called
optimism in the face of uncertainty okay
so what happens with this kind of
algorithm is that somehow this is able
to trade off exploitation and
exploration so to kind of do that you
need some randomization and so it so
happens that an index policy like this
is able to achieve that and it is able
to achieve that in an optimal way so
this is just a sample average from the
from tossing coin I the guy is the
number of times up to time T that you
have picked coin I so what happens is
that when you pick one I this is going
to go down because di is going to
increase right if you don't choose I
then it is this index value increases as
square root log T okay so it's not
strictly speaking upper conference bound
because it is increasing I mean as you
have more samples you would expect the
upper conference bound to decrease but
that's not really happening there is
this inflation factor in this index okay
so it's a proxy for upper confidence
mouth okay so the point is that that
this algorithm
is able to kind of you know do some
randomization and it trades off
exploration and exploitation which is
optimal at least in the or which is
order optimal now the other thing that
happens with this is that if you look at
what the algum does is that it does
exploration that gets based
exponentially apart okay and that's the
reason why you know regret grows as
locti okay but turns out this is not the
only way that we can solve a problem
like this so here is another way so so
here what you do is you maintain a
posterior distribution over the unknown
parameters and then you sample from the
posterior distribution and then you just
pick the coin that gives the highest
sample right so very simple intuitive
you know natural algorithm and indeed it
was you know in back in the 1930s when
Thompson was thinking of a similar
problem this is what he proposed to do
of course no proof and it's somehow it
so happened that this was lost and then
in 2011 a couple of guys in Yahoo
research they discovered this
rediscovered this algorithm and they
found that numerically it performs even
better than UCB type algorithms and and
then a year later there was a proof of
regret for this algorithm and and you
know and it turns out that regret grows
as locti for this algorithm as well ok
so now the so you know as I was saying
it's very not simple natural idea right
but what's really happening here is that
that you're really doing randomization
based on posterior sampling and it's
happening in a way that it is able to
kind of you know trade-off exploration
and exploitation in an optimal manner
right so so another alternative to kind
of to for the emultion bounded problem
now the other thing that's happening
here is that it may not be apparent when
you look at the simple two unbounded
problem
but when you try to generalize UCB type
algorithms you have to do a lot of
computation so you have to you know I've
read instant of time you have to solve
an optimization problem but here there
is no optimization problem that you're
solving so all you doing is you're just
doing sampling so computationally it is
better it has superior numerical
performance and it is computationally
simpler okay so now after all this now
let's go revisit the problem that I had
set out with which is to find a learning
policy for an unknown MDP and the
learning policy of course is going to be
a function of the entire history that
you see up to time T and we're going to
we would like this learning policy to
search over some some parameter space
theta okay and specifically the
objective of learning is to minimize the
rate of growth of regret okay so this is
just a counterpart of regret that we saw
earlier now
one lower bound that is known for this
is square root T so as opposed to the
finite on Bennie's problem where the
lower bound is log T here you cannot
achieve log T you can add the scatter a
square root T okay so now I guess I have
motivated why we should consider
posterior sampling based learning policy
for this problem specifically you know
it's computationally simpler so now
let's see how one can do that so it's
you know the idea behind the algún is
very very natural so you divide time
into episodes and these episodes have
dynamic the daylon's changes dynamically
and then so at the beginning of the
episode you so you're maintaining a
posterior over the unknown parameters
you sample from those parameters and
then you can you pretend that the those
are the true parameters you compute a
policy and then you use that policy for
the rest of the episode okay so that's
the policy so UX at the beginning of the
episode you explore then you exploit and
then you resample then you compute a
policy again then you exploit again
etcetera etcetera okay so where is
you know natural algorithm the only
thing we need to worry about is how
should we adjust the length of the
episode right or D if in other words
what should the exploration schedule be
that's the thing we need to worry about
so so one so that two turns out that
there are two things that determine what
the length of the episode will be one is
that the episode is increasing we
increase the episode by one every time
okay and I'll revisit this why we are
doing this by increasing the one every
time so at every time instant so T two
is going to be t1 plus one okay so it
cannot be larger than that but this is
sometimes this doesn't work so we also
need to keep track of the following that
we we keep track of the the number of
visits to some through each state action
pair and if at any time instant T the
number of visits to state state action
pair X U is greater than twice the
number of visits to X U at time at the
beginning of the episode then it means
that this current policy is not doing
enough exploration so you need to end
this episode you need to resample
compute a new policy and then begin all
over again okay so like I said this is
the only thing you need to design
everything else is sort of apparent this
is natural way to design the rest of the
algorithm and then the other thing is
that every time instant you are you're
updating the posterior using Bayes rule
that's it
okay so there's no optimization it's
just well okay so there is a of course
devil is in the details one thing is
that you have to compute the policy at
the beginning of the episode you can use
it you can do that using your favorite
dynamic programming algorithm okay
unfortunately there is no way around it
you know you can do that approximately
or you can do that exactly but there's
no way around it okay all right okay so
so what we can show is that for this
algorithm the regret so Yuri sample the
parameters T so parameter theta is just
the transition probability of the MDP
and then you solve a dynamic programming
problem you you can use value iteration
policy tration yeah and then you get
policy PI star which would correspond to
if the true parameter was theta right
and then you just continue for the rest
of the episode so that's a very good
question so in principle you can
assuming that you have some knowledge
already some information already so you
can use that prior but in practice what
happens is that you use some nice prior
like a Gaussian prior or something or
beta prior or so that the computation in
the updating the posterior is easy so
that's what is typically done okay so so
what we can show is that the regret is
upper bounded by a square root T optical
logarithmic factor and this is not
asymptotic and all the constants and
everything is known okay so and the
other thing to note here is that
actually does scale sort of linearly the
upper bound scales linearly in the state
space size and it's a square root in the
action space size and like I was said
that you you know the altom works even
you know you can use approximately
optimal policies and this album will
still work now why can't the episode
length increase more than one but each
time that's not an artifact of the proof
in fact empirically we found that you
can't do more than that now is there
another algorithm that you know that can
have sort of a better schedule we don't
know but we tried other schedules and it
turns out that you know by increase the
episode length by one or by some
constant is the best you can do you
can't increase it for example in youcb
algorithm you can increase the
exploration
time between explorations exponentially
you can actually have a deterministic
schedule and it'll still work but that
doesn't happen here that's I think it's
seems to be sort of you know that for
this problem you can't do that okay
so just to give you a sense of whether
it works or not numerically so this is
tested on a some benchmark problem
called reverse Wham and it's the this is
this corresponds to an algorithm called
you see RL 2 and at least it seems that
the regret is growing sub linearly which
means that if you look at per unit Egret
you are gonna have convergence but for
this algorithm which is lazy PS RL the
regret is going linearly and you may not
even get convergence to the to the
optimal policy and then there is another
algorithm TSM DP where which where you
need to specify a recurrent state so if
you specify a good record state its
turns out that it performs quite well
but otherwise it doesn't okay so that's
as far as we know it's the state of the
art now of course there is the earlier
you know literature in stochastic
adaptive control but you know those give
asymptotic guarantees okay just a quick
word about proof the key I mean there is
a lot of levers you need to crank but
it's mostly straightforward the keys
that you need to ensure that this
property that for therefore the
algorithm that expectation of the any
function of the parameter theta K and a
random variable X which is adaptive to
to the filtration generated by the
history that's equal to the expectation
of the function of the true parameter
and the same random variable so this is
so this is what you need to check when
you're designing the algorithm
everything else is housekeeping
most of the reinforcement learning
literature they parameterize the value
function linear basis functions or
something again your parameterizing the
probability transition matrix so can you
say something about when one is better
or worse
so reinforcement so the way I understand
it reinforcement learning is about two
problems one is sort of the dynamic
programming part if you will right which
is what you're referring to so you know
if you have a lot state space or
continuous state space then you have to
do function approximation and you can
either do that with value functions on
the policy space etc but the other is
the exploration and it's sort of how
should you explore so usually there is
no prescription for that right there is
that's more or less an open problem so
this is a prescription for how should
you explore now you can so you are
computing so at the beginning of every
every episode you are computing a policy
you can compute that policy using exact
value iteration or policy iteration or
you can use any kind of function
approximation your networks so yeah so
that's somewhat an orthogonal issue to
this that is right image for this model
it's not a problem and you have finite
state space and finite action space it's
a you know there are finite number of
parameters that you need to worry about
that completely specifies the model so
that's not an issue but the number of
parameters is finite
right there is there is no assumption so
this is fully parameterize in the sense
that right so I mean these Thetas live
in some product of probability simplex
is right that's right that's right
that's lead yeah okay all right okay so
the sort of main conclusion from here
this is that you know these kind of
posterior sampling based algorithms
somehow they're able to do randomization
such that in a sort of you know that you
you you you can learn at the optimal
rate if you will right the question is
whether now whether that this can go
beyond just this model right or not okay
so for that we have five minutes okay so
for that let me let's look at stochastic
linear system with unknown parameters so
it's the standard model and then the
parameters a and B are unknown and we're
going to consider a quadratic cost but
that's really just for the reasons of
tractability because for that that's
that's the model for which we can
compute something right and again the
objective is regret so we switched from
considering reward to cost but
everything is more or less the same and
of course for this model we know that
there is an optimal control policy which
is linear so you just solve the solution
of riccati equation and then that gives
you the gain and then you have a linear
policy sorry optimal policy okay so one
assumption we are going to make is that
in the in the parameter set for every
theta there is a unique positive
definite solution to the riccati
equation otherwise we can't do any
computation so right
okay all right so just a quick word
about sort of you know adaptive control
so of course this is not a new problem
so the the the key idea in at least in
most of adaptive control classical
adaptive control is certainty
equivalents and also it is well
understood that it doesn't always work
there are counter examples right and
that is why I think the cost bias
maximum likelihood approach was
introduced by Campion Kumar for the same
problem and you know it asymptotic Lee
converges to the to the optimal policy
recently people have been worrying about
non asymptotic performance and so there
is you know few algorithms but these are
of the flavor of optimism in the face of
uncertainty so you can think of those
desires generalization of the UCP idea
but they end up they have to do lot of
computations so every time instant you
know when you we need to to recompute a
policy you have to do solve become
optimization problem okay
and yeah that's what it is now so how
would one construct a posterior sampling
algorithm for this so it's exactly the
same idea you divide time into episodes
which have dynamic length and the length
of the episode increases by one each
time unless you're not doing enough
exploration and the way we keep track of
not doing enough exploration is you are
getting an estimate of the parameter and
its covariance so if the covariance
becomes half of or determine of the
covariance is half of what it was at the
beginning of the episode it means you
are not doing enough exploration
you must it's better to just three
sample recompute and start all over
again so to speak okay so yeah so that's
the algorithm and so this is this is so
and it works in the sense that so this
is this is showing per unit regret with
the number of iterations you know there
are two plots here you can ignore that I
mean that's sort of an artifact of the
simulation but
basically you see that for an open-loop
stable system the per-unit Egret is well
it's decreasing I mean and I think at
least the theorem implies there
converges to zero one can conclude that
from the plot and even for even if the
open-loop system is unstable you see
that the per unit Egret decreases and
seems to converge to zero and fact you
can prove that the expected regret is
bounded by a square root T up the
logarithmic factor now one thing that is
you know we do have to assume that the
with the algorithm will remain will keep
the system or a closed loop stable okay
so this is the artifact of the proof
unfortunately we have not been able to
get rid of this as of now but in the
simulations it never seems to come into
play so all right with that so so I
introduced a posterior sampling based
learning to control algorithms for MVPs
and linear stochastic systems and as I
mentioned so you know initially I was a
little bit skeptical about this but it
seemed seems to sort of it's a very does
exploration versus exploitation in a
very structured way meaning that it's
doing randomization but it's a very
systematic way of kind of design it's
well known in adaptive control that you
can add randomization and then you know
you know you can get around the problem
that sentiment of equals doesn't hold
right so this is sort of a very
systematic way of doing that right and
the results in a very natural design in
some other class of problem we have seen
that you can design a deterministic
schedule of exploration and that works
for specifically for finite unbounded
problems we don't know if we can do that
here as of now you know I believe that
should be possible but as of now we
couldn't do that
and now another issue which is kind of
what was asked was you know
you know can this be combined with that
you know can can you can this be
extended to continued state space MDPs
so I believe so we don't have that yet
so I believe that it is an orthogonal
issue so you could do function
approximation in finding the the optimal
policy at the beginning of every episode
and it should be possible to kind of
extend this and I believe there is a
potential to kind of address you know
sort of learning for time varying
systems as well where let's say the
parameter is is varying according to
Markov chain or something like that but
again we don't have that yet all right
so with that I'll stop here so thank you
[Applause]
dependence on the prior so so that's a
very good question so that's buried in
the expectation so it's expectation of
the regret upper bounded by something so
the expectation is with respect that
prior its base grade yeah but the upper
bound is independent of that not sure I
understand so
you know this a and B are oh no and you
want to learn that so have you that's
what we're doing right ear and B are
unknown Oh cost function Q and R in the
cost no we have not I don't know I
probably it should not I mean it should
be possible to do it but I don't know
yeah yeah yeah it's that should not be a
different be difficult in any case C you
know you probably only need a finite
number of samples to actually infer Q
and R and after that you know it right
because you you get you get to see the
cost the per stage cost exactly and even
if you don't know Q and R you know X you
know you so from some temples you can
compute that the more sorry
[Applause]